[Music]
[Applause]
hi everyone welcome to the table this
hasn't been a typical week it's been
heavy and full of weight and grief and
burden and so it didn't feel right to go
into our usual announcements and and
that kind of thing but I will say that
I'm really really glad that you chose to
be here with us right now and hope that
this time together provides some refuge
some comfort some truth and some
sanctuary for you so I just wanted to
share some words from my own reflecting
and journaling from this week and then
we'll pray and then we'll head into
worship I have so many words yet none
are adequate right now they are too
little too late and they're from someone
who is who more often clings to comfort
and status quo than speaks out in
solidarity and discomfort I am noticing
different this time how the protests the
fires the damage are not the result of
the latest hashtags but centuries of
whiteness that refuses to see to listen
to and believe the experiences of black
people
crushed daily under the knee of
oppressive and unjust systems I'm
noticing narratives that play into my
own baked-in biases they go largely
unchallenged in our white families
churches schools and communities I'm
noticing these narratives
with a nation founded on a system of
hierarchy where white people get to be
at the top and black people indigenous
people and people of color are at the
bottom and it becomes even more
dangerous and unjust and unchristian I
might add the system allows me to get
the unearned benefit of the doubt while
a black person gets the gaze of
suspicion before either of us speaks a
single word this system that continues
to assign different value despite each
person being made in the beautiful
sacred image of God this system that
continues to tell me that as a white
person I am just normal when I look
deeper really tells me and reinforces
daily that I am superior better somehow
deserving of these unearned benefits how
is this christ-like in any way how is
this the kingdom of God this system of
hierarchy that I find as normal is
directly opposed to the heart of God and
the way of Jesus and it's literally
costing black people and people of color
their lives it is a sin that constantly
seeks to steal kill and destroy thoughts
prayers and platitudes are not going to
cut it this time and here's the thing
black people and especially black women
have been talking and sharing and
warning about this for a long long time
they've understood the urgency but those
of us who are white have not I now
realize that I have blood on my hands I
am accountable for each hashtag each act
of violence and police brutality for
each time black people deal with grief
upon grief the terror of modern day
lynchings the trauma of black bodies
being made as spectacle as the killings
are recorded and replayed over and over
and over again the visceral rage and
despair and burden of justice delayed
and denied over and over and over again
when is it enough those of us who are
white Jesus followers must commit to
acknowledging and rooting out this sin
in our own hearts we have to be willing
to sit in the discomfort of uncovering
interrogating and dismantling our own
unconscious biases assumptions and
complicity let it begin with me let it
begin with you let it begin here at the
table and let it begin now let's pray
God so often we say break our hearts for
what break you breaks yours and we pray
shine your light on in justices and show
us the way and I admit and confess that
you have done that over and over and
over again it is us white people that
have failed to listen failed to heed
failed to put feet to the gospel that we
profess so god I'm so thankful that you
continue to show us the way that it's
not a mystery you've laid it all out in
the Bible through prophets through
parables through Jesus god help us help
us and may we commit to doing the work
to not just love with words and tongues
but with actions and feet and love that
is willing to stand in solidarity to lay
our very lives down for others who are
losing their very lives and
help us all hold fast to your anchor of
hope truth compassion justice that your
arms and your hands are big enough for
all of this and that you are the way the
truth and the life in Jesus name Amen
[Music]
oh my god shine your light on my leave
God shine your light know that we might
be
[Music]
oh that is inside of me screams come
back
[Music]
if you feel
if you feel those same
if you fail time
[Music]
feel lost and tired this is your song
Brogan
[Music]
I ain't giving up no come back
if you feel loved if you feel
if you feel tired
see you feel lost and time this is your
song
[Music]
you feel lost and tired
this is your song
[Music]
I got shine your light on us we might
leave oh my god
shine your light on us that we might
leave
[Music]
you
now
Oh
[Music]
[Applause]
god I just want to leave space and room
in our hearts 10 name when things are
not okay and it's so much easier
sometimes to try to find a bow to wrap
it all up with or some kind of cliche
phrase that makes us feel better in the
moment but right now I just make space
to name that things are not okay and we
grieve that together and we look to you
together and we ask God that you would
surround us that you would be near to
the brokenhearted that you would be
close to the vulnerable to the Forgotten
to the ones on the fringe to the ones
who are fighting even for their lives
god I pray that you would be close and
that our hands and our feet would be
ready to support and lift them up God to
be a voice for the voiceless to be the
body of Christ that looks out for the
widow and the orphan and the vulnerable
and the Forgotten and the fringes
God show us how to be your hands in your
feet we love you and we know that we
don't get it right all the time so thank
you for your grace
in our lives help us as we stumble our
way through
[Music]
the good evening everyone
grace and peace and I know I say that
every week and I mean it every week but
this one even more than others and I
just want to welcome you all to the
table
this evening so we are in this is part
three of our series on lament and lament
giving voice to our grief and honestly
just like our last series which many of
you will recall was on tranquility it
has again proved really timely and so
the the title of my message specific to
tonight is the weight of the world so it
was this past Wednesday right after my
morning prayers I went on Facebook and
came across the footage of George Floyd
the african-american man from
Minneapolis originally from Houston but
had been there in Minneapolis for a few
years and and I watched the video of him
being slowly choked to death by a white
police officer and this this of course
it came right on the heels of the other
unjust deaths of Ahmad are buried and
Brianna's hailer in just the last few
weeks and those are themselves of course
part of a much longer history and so
there I am I'm staring at Facebook and I
want to say something I mean a guy
should say something I want to and so I
proceeded to write a few words in order
to share you know this post that had
come across the video but the words I
type they just didn't seem quite right
and so I deleted them and then I wrote
more words but those were not enough and
so again they were deleted and then more
words and then delete it and on and on
this went and I realized in that moment
that I was speechless not because I
didn't have thoughts
oceans anger but but because all of my
words seemed so feeble but they were
almost like an elderly person my words
were like doubled over attempting to
carry too heavy a load they they simply
could not bear the burden that I longed
for them to carry and and this this
picture of a person bent over by their
burden it reminded me of the passage I'd
already been researching that week for
my message which was and is tonight
Psalm chapter 55 verses 17 through 22
and let's go ahead and read this
together
verse 17 evening and morning and at noon
I utter my complaint in Mon and he hears
my voice he redeems he being God he
redeems my soul and safety from the
battle that I waged for many are arrayed
against me God will give ear and humble
them he who is enthroned from of old
Sayla and that means likely on pause of
contemplate because they do not change
and do not fear God my companion
stretched out his hand against his
friends he violated his covenant his
speech was smooth as butter yet war was
in his heart his words were softer than
oil and yet they were drawn swords cast
your burden on the Lord and He will
sustain you he will never permit the
righteous to be moved and of course it's
it's that last line that I think is a
picture of what is happening when we
lament you see lament is not only verse
17 complaint and moaning and he hears my
voice which is in other words like
but it's also verse 22 a a casting of
our burden on to the Lord it is an
unburdening of ourselves a shifting the
weight from ourselves to God there's a
sculpture titled fallen Caryatid carries
her stone this is by the the french
sculptor Auguste Rodin and Gary's gonna
put that up so I think this it captures
this this burdening of the human very
powerfully you'll notice that her
posture with you know her head it's like
displaced and then the bent knees in a
sitting position and it's just showing
what it is like to bear a burden that
you cannot sustain alone there's there's
nothing about this image that says I
think she's about to do it look she's
just an inch away from burying it
herself
correct I think you know it's clear the
the stone the bird it is too heavy the
burden is too great
now of course to be human is to carry
certain burdens we carry the burden of
toiling for our daily bread we we carry
the burden of raising children the
burden of run-of-the-mill sickness like
getting a five-day cold to some degree
all of us have borne the burden of the
last few months with the quarantine but
what theologian Janine Fletcher Hill and
herself she's actually drawn on the work
of a philosopher named Mark C Taylor
which she names is that in an ideal
world we would quote share the weight of
the world using our individual power to
maintain the well-being of not only
ourselves right isn't that the American
Way who is focused on the selves the
religion of self not only ourselves but
of the collective so in theory this is
what we could do the question is do we
know he'll continues that instead quote
the weight of the
world is shifted on to some and lifted
from others and of course you only have
to look around to see how that has
played out in our world in in very real
ways whether you think of the struggle
between rich and poor master/slave
male/female gay and straight black white
in fact one way to view politics is this
kind of massive debate backed ultimately
by force of whose shoulders the weight
of the world will be placed upon you see
one way to read Psalm 55 is as an
individual person struggling with their
personal burden but actually if you read
it closely you'll you'll you'll catch
that this person this is not someone
struggling with seasonal allergies or
their 8:00 to 5:00 job being boring
instead there there's a social dimension
to their suffering so verse 17 kind of
frames that evening and morning in at
noon I utter my complaint and I moan so
you can hear their the psalmist
struggling under the weight of the world
which begs the question why verse 18 for
many are arrayed right coming against me
God will give ear and humbled them he
who isn't thrown from of old why because
they do not change and do not fear God
and then the context it shifts and now
it's not the many the them rather there
is someone that our writer thought they
could trust someone who was supposed to
be there to help carry the weight of the
world to help carry this burden but
instead verse 20 my companion stretched
out his hand against his friends he
violated his
covenant and what is the Covenant what
what is it what what do companions and
brothers and sisters friends co-workers
fellow citizens and certainly people in
a church family what are they supposed
to do they're supposed to help unburden
they're supposed to help carry the
weight of the world right that's the
Covenant to love one another as as Jesus
said but what happens verse 21
his speech oh it was smooth as butter
and yet war was in his heart his words
softer than oil yet they were drawn
swords in other words this this brother
or sister who was supposed to be a
burden bearer has through their actions
actually added to the weight in the
burden of the psalmist's life and
apparently not in some small way but in
a way that has broken the psalmist's
heart she is like Rodin sculpture being
crushed and as I watched George Floyd on
the ground I saw Rodin sculpture in my
mind's eye and I thought of the long
history that brought us to that moment
all of the precious people and bodies
made in the image of God crushed the
massive failure of white America to keep
the Covenant our failure to love but
thankfully the story doesn't have to end
there and we'll get more into this next
week about how lament leads to hope and
action but the song doesn't in there
either does it
instead the psalmist says cast your
burden on the Lord and He will sustain
you and that is the precious
grit of someone who has experienced the
crushing burden of oppression and evil
and that's that's a truth that that
extends to all of us that no matter who
has abandoned you that God is there to
help shoulder that burden and yes our
brothers and our sisters should be there
to help us carry the weight of the world
and yes we want to be about the work of
the kingdom of God where love and
justice reign but in the meantime we can
make it how cast your burden on the Lord
and He will sustain you you see there's
something powerful that can happen
psychologically um you might say
existentially I don't just mean like in
the heavenlies or in the spiritual part
of us I mean in our lived experience
when we have a deep faith in the God of
love who knows us who numbers the hairs
on our head who upholds and nourishes
and sustains us in the year 1916 Charles
a tindley he's an african-american
composer and musician and one of the
founders of American gospel music and he
wrote the song take your burden to the
Lord and leave it there it's based of
course on on the psalm we've been in
today Psalm 55 in specifically verse 22
and this was it was very popular the
song back primarily in black churches
and among gospel blues artists of that
era but it went more mainstream in the
1920s when it was picked up by another
African American musician named
Washington Phillips and you can actually
find an original recording of it on
YouTube I encourage you to go online
look that up later
just search Washington Phillips take
your burdens of Lord leave it there now
I named
that background that history because I
think without it this song and perhaps
the the kind of conclusion of my talk
tonight it could come across as overly
sentimental like oh you're facing a
problem you just turn it over to the
Lord but but when a song like this is
placed on the lips of a black person or
a black church in the United States in
1916 I think you can hear that at its
best it's a song of survival it's a song
that's inviting us to say no matter what
comes my way I have a God who is on my
side who gives me hope in the midst of
what appears to be an absolutely
hopeless situation the one who lifts up
my head the one who lifts my burden and
so in just a moment Carter Livingston
our very own Carter is gonna be who's
gonna go ahead and play that song um but
before he does that I want to say just
one more thing to my white brothers and
sisters let's not be silent in the face
of injustice and suffering resulting
from racial discrimination let's help to
remove the crushing burden that racism
perpetuates in our country and to my
brothers and sisters of color and in
light of the events of this week
especially those who identify as African
American you are not alone we see you we
love you
we're with you we go ahead and pray with
me or Jesus we are a stumbling bumbling
sinful people there are sins and in
justices that we can see and even ones
that we are completely and utterly blind
to God we lament them all the pain they
have brought others the weight of the
world
that has shifted on to others God may
you teach us to be a burden lifting
people not a burden contributing people
and to all of those weighed down by
burdens they do not know whether or not
they can sustain or would you sustain
them and may they find rest in the God
of love in justice so Lord lead us into
a new day of compassion and of justice
amen
[Music]
in the world from you and whole of it's
alright it's cool and you have to get
along with a meager fare just remember
it is word that means that little bird
take the bird run low leave it there
mean it there leave it there take your
bird and Franz you Lord and leave it
there if you trust and never doubt he
will surely bring you well take about
two look meal it there
[Music]
if your body suffers pain and your hot
New York and regain and your soul is all
sinking in the spare
jesus knows the pain you feel you can
save and he can he'll take your throat
to Lord and me it'll mean it there won't
leave it there take your burden to the
north leave it there
if you trust and never doubt you show
leaving you well take it buddy
to the load
[Music]
when your enemy's a sin and your heart
begins to fail don't forget that God in
heaven answers prayer
he will make way for you and lead you
safely through take your burden too low
[Music]
leave it there Mimi they're taking
burden to the Lord leave it there if you
trust and never doubt he will surely
bring you out take your burden
[Music]
you've seen it all go by but chance you
wonder why sorrow pain and misery are
everywhere
he will light up your Lord put your feet
back on the road take your bird to the
Lord maybe they'll leave it there or
leave it there take your burden to the
Lord and leave it if you trust and live
it down
we will surely bring you out take your
burden too low even if you trust and
never doubt he will surely bring you out
take your burden to the low and even
there
[Music]
[Applause]
thanks Carter
this is a poem that I wrote about race
in America through the lens of white
Christianity our quiet is violence
our silence is loud amplifying fear
drowning out sounds of those who speak
truth like a prophet in her own town
still we cling to the status quo while
the ground
cries out begging for change
generational doubt awake though you
sleepers open your eyes
listen to those constantly pushed to the
side their soul cries our justice their
anger is right despair that turns tables
as we sit idly by
can we see they are us we are them we
are we connected by glory and image and
grief
what did shall we do Lord what do you
require listen believe and stand with
the tired
their bodies are weary disappointment so
deep ashes are heavy and the mask is
weak wil seeds of change ever come or as
Empire what's been sown we wash our
hands like Pilate as the rooster crows
on thank you Karen and thank you
everyone who contributed to the service
tonight
and I wanted to also thank you
all of you who joined us this evening
and I know many of you are probably
wondering like what what you can do
actually just saw Stephanie and
commented something similar similar
question and I'm glad you asked because
if you're looking to help in like a
practical tangible way you can go to
Minnesota freedom fun org and make a
contribution there they're basically
there supporting various nonprofits who
are just doing really good
basically protests in racial justice
work in that that state in and there in
Minnesota in Minneapolis so Minnesota
freedom fund org is one really kind of
practical tangible thing you can do and
I'm also we as a church from time to
time we offer a class that it was kind
of formally called whiteness 101 but
it's it's put on by be the bridge or the
the material we used on curriculum and
it's it's led by Karen minor and they're
actually just wrap wrapping up a course
that they're going through so we haven't
yet scheduled the next one but it'll be
coming you know at some point in the
future and in really the purpose of that
course is to serve as an introduction to
ideas of like systemic racism and such
so that specifically as white folks we
can be less ignorant about our history
in the present moment
so that's really who the class is for is
is folks yeah white folks and not so
much people of color so anyway if you're
interested in that you can go ahead and
kick us a message like on Facebook kick
me a message just say hey I'd love to be
notified next time that class is offered
and we're happy to umm ya can keep you
in the loop on that so again thank you
so much for joining us and I know it's
it's just been an incredibly difficult
week but in the midst of it we just want
you to know you're not alone we love you
we're there for you so if you have needs
you need prayer you just need some
community a place to process and talk
please don't walk through this alone
reach out and you want to be in touch so
let me close with this you are
God's servants you're gifted with dreams
you're gifted with visions and upon you
rest the grace of God like flames of
fire go love serve the Lord in the
strength of the Holy Spirit I'll be with
you all a great week
you